I couldn't even get cast as an Italian,
I'll never forget where
there was a party scene,
is this 300 guests, (laughing) I said no.
But the fear is the fuel that
we use for overachievement.
If I wasn't afraid at times,
I wouldn't work as hard.
You've got to take chances,
you've got to gamble,
and if you win 51% of the
time, you've got it made.
- He's an American actor,
filmmaker and screenwriter.
He's best known for his
roles as Rocky Balboa,
and John Rambo.
Philadelphia also has a
statue of his Rocky character
permanently placed by the Museum of Art.
He's Sylvester Stallone,
and here's my take
on his Top Ten Rules
for Success, volume two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well.
Enjoy!
(high energy music)
- I truly believe, and
people throw the word around,
dreams, it's all about
dreams, and by the way,
dreams cost nothing, they're free.
The hard part is just keeping them going,
and please keep them
going because we're here
for one simple reason,
he believed in the dream,
I believed in the dream,
and our dreams come true,
and there's no reason every
one of yours can't either.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Let's start from the beginning.
Was there ever a time
that you doubted yourself?
- Yeah, you know I
thought, when I lived in
basically this flophouse, it's
$26 a week, very transient,
and you shared a floor with 10 people,
you don't know anybody on
the plan, literally no one.
- I think I recall you saying,
you're acting at one point,
The Godfather, and you said
you couldn't even get in a...
- (laughing) I couldn't
even get cast as an Italian,
I never forget where
there was a party scene,
is this 300 guests? (laughing) I said no.
I go, what part of me didn't make it
past the Italian identification aspect,
he goes, eh, I don't know,
you just don't fit in,
I went, wow,
God's telling me something.
- That's got to (laughing)
- That's got to play with
your psyche a little bit!
- Little bit.
- I don't know.
But it didn't, and you decided
to take matters into your
own hands, by writing Rocky.
- Y'know, I been comin'
here for six years,
six years you been stickin' it to me,
I want to know how come.
- You want to know?
- I want to know!
- Okay I'm going to tell ya!
'Cause you had the talent
to become a good fighter,
and instead of that, you
became a lane breaker.
- You were able to write Rocky
in three and a half days.
The movie that went on to be Best Picture,
you wrote in three and a half days?
- Yes, yes.
- Was it just flowing out of you?
- In a way it was, I knew that this
was going to be very flawed,
but if I could get from
the beginning to the end,
with some semblance of a character,
then I'll repair the rest along the way.
- And you want to star in
it, and you're told no,
you were even offered $250,000--
- 360.
- 360, you're a struggling actor.
- Ooh...
- You can't make ends meet.
- No.
- You're getting offerred all this money,
but you didn't take it.
- No, I just didn't understand
how the rules of life
were played at that point, but
this character, I understood.
If I had to rewind the clock ten years,
I would have insisted, by people
that were close to me, that
please, push me into very unsafe projects,
at least every other one.
I think it's professionally responsible
to not continue to remake the
same film over and over again,
you know, what's tonight?
Turkey TV dinner, turkey TV dinner...
There's always fear, and
I even put it in Rocky II,
that he's, "I'm afraid, I'm afraid."
But the fear is the fuel that
we use for overachievement.
If I wasn't afraid at times,
I wouldn't work as hard,
'cause the fear is, I don't
want to sit back in mediocrity,
I don't want to to just say,
I want to rest on my laurels,
so I hear footsteps all the time,
and I know that I only have
a certain amount of time
and I don't want to waste it,
because it's gone so quickly,
since Rocky it's been almost
seven and a half, eight years,
I think that Don and I are
just overachievers because
we know that there's only a
certain amount of productivity
in a day and we don't want to waste it.
I am at the whims of the
character that I play,
that's who people think I
am, not Sylvester Stallone.
Most people, when I go
around the world, it's like,
Hey Rocky, hey Rambo, it's not you.
In one way it's very
flattering, you know, it's like,
you've come up with
something that they enjoy,
but I know that if I
gave them another Rocky,
another Rambo all the time,
they would sour on it,
you know, even though I do
things that aren't successful,
the main thing in my work ethic,
is you've got to take
chances, you've got to gamble,
and if you win 51% of the
time, you've got it made.
- What do you mean,
don't think about this,
when you starting treatment?
I'm not doing no chemotherapy.
I'm not crazy at all.
If I could take everything that was good,
and put it into a bowl or
something, and say hey, here,
I'd like to buy one more
day with my wife, I'd do it.
Everything I got, is
moved on, and I'm here.
I never wanted to do this movie.
I thought, sick Rocky is so
counter-intuitive to what
Rocky really is designed for.
I just lay there, I said,
can someone else be sick
in the movie and not me,
'cause I've never done that.
My wife goes, "You're
a coward," and I went,
"You know that's kind of a harsh word"
he goes "No no, you're yellow
basically, you're a coward."
It goes against every
undeclared artistic rule,
if you're afraid of something,
that's the commitment
of the artist, that's his
duty, to pursue the unknown,
to go someplace where he's
literally at odds with himself.
- [Adonis] "You all right there, old man?"
- [Rocky] "Yeah."
You know if you look hard enough,
you can see your whole life from up here.
- [Adonis] How does it look?
- [Rocky] Not bad at all.
- [Narrator] Stallone wrote a
screenplay for a boxing film
called Rocky with himself as the lead.
The studio loved the script,
but wanted Sly to step aside
for a big name actor.
Despite intense pressure,
Stallone refused to give in.
- You have to try, you have
to see if you really are
what you think you are,
and by that I mean,
I wanted one chance to prove
whether I was a good actor,
or that I was a lousy actor,
or whether I should go
get a Dairy Queen stand
or what I should do,
or even maybe I should get out of acting,
and I just needed one vehicle to prove it.
I had to be up there just enough to say,
"Jesus, you stink
Stallone," or, "Not bad!"
- [Narrator] The studio finally agreed.
Sly gave it 100%.
- I started about five
months into training,
and I had a regime of
abstaining from hacky pracky,
and eating a lot of meat, and developing
a Tyrannosaurus Rex mentality,
running and sparring
and taking the bruises, but I felt
that that came out in the film.
I knew this was my one shot
and I wasn't about to cheat
on it, I wasn't about to come in there
and look like Tinkerbell for
an hour and a half, I had this,
"Oh God if I stink at least
let me skink with class!"
Something, and geez, it was so great.
In arm wrestling rules,
if you lift out of the cup
like this, that does
disqualify, it disqualifies...
- You had cheated.
- Well let's just say I
lost my Australian rules.
- [Derryn] Well let's have
a quick look at it again
and just see how rough it really was.
- [Sylvester] All right.
Now, in arm wrestling the
elbow must remain on the table.
Am I right?
- Evening up there, yeah.
- Okay, now this man, here we go,
and he's very strong, this guy is strong,
all right here we go,
he is hitting himself, the match is over,
and now he is going north,
up up up up excuse me
- [Derryn] You see he's
using his hand, his arm
to lift his other arm.
- [Sylvester] I mean,
I'm pointing, thank you,
end of match.
Now, we should cut the tape
at this point (laughing)
- Not bad, but okay, even
at a time like that...
- No, I got to say, this guy is strong,
he's strong.
- But do you hate losing?
- No, you see, I don't, I
don't, that's my philosophy,
you go out, you try,
sometimes you get bad breaks,
sometimes people don't play by the rules,
whatever it is, but nah,
I'm not one of those people
who are obsessed with it.
I'm competitive, oh yeah,
I'm real competitive,
but I've never been like
obsessed with, "I must go back."
I like to try until the end,
like if I'm working on a character,
I want to push and push and
push until the breaking point
but I've never been like in
sports where I have to go out,
matter of fact, I play on a
football team, we had a ten game
season, we were O and 10 for this season.
O and 10.
- You lost 10.
- And I was the captain, you
know what I mean, it's like,
how do you get, so I'm used to it.
Whenever you're saying Rocky,
I always feel as though
we're giving a vote of confidence
for these great athletes,
for real, you know I've never
pretended to be a boxer,
I don't possess those skills,
but what I do think I have
is an understanding of what
goes on outside the ring.
Outside the ring is sometimes
maybe even a bigger struggle
than what goes on inside the ring,
and if I was able to capture that,
then I believe you can
identify more with a fighter
but more than that, we also realize
that our life is a constant battle,
sometimes I write things
in Rocky that may seem
a little precious as they
say, or a little sentimental,
but I truly believe it's
not how hard you can hit,
it's how hard you can get
hit, and keep moving forward,
because that's really what
does make the difference
in your life, (audience
members cheering) you know.
(audience applauds)
It really does.
You're all fantastic.
These men here have always been
held in a special reverence
for me, greatest athletes in
the world, but more than that,
they are our connection to the past,
and our way to the
future, they are the guys
that go there and take the blows
and show that if you really
put it out there on the line,
you are a champion.
You may not be the champion of the world
but you'll be the champion of your life,
and yo, Adrian, I did it!
(audience cheers and applauds)
I think that personal ambition
is worth fighting for,
it really is something that
if you don't fight for it,
you're going to regret it
for the rest of your life,
and if you regret it, you
could be an unhappy person,
if you're an unhappy person
it can affect your family,
so you can see the chain of
command all the way down,
it can be pretty devastating.
The common answer is we
fight for family, yeah,
but fighting for family starts with you,
so you got to fight for peace
of mind, that's what I think,
you have to go for, what
makes you happy enough
in your life that you want
to make other people happy?
I don't know about anyone
else, but I really feel
it's a privilege to be here tonight,
and I'm going to try my best to, what?
(audience laughing and cheering)
- You stole my script!
You stole my script, don't you dare--
(audience cheering and applauding)
No, I'm sorry, I watched the
movie, you stole my script,
all that was me--
- You been puttin' me on for years, Ali--
- Show me what you're going to
do, show me what you can do!
- Know my real name, doncha?
(audience laughing and applauding)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video,
what was the most important
lesson that you learned,
that blew your mind, that
you're going to immediately
apply to your life or
your business somehow,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
Also if you want to nominate someone
for the next top ten video,
please check the description
for a link to a video where
you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Bailey Cooper,
thank you so much Bailey for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and putting
it in your YouTube video,
I really appreciate the support man,
and I'm glad you're enjoying the read.
- Your One Word, by Evan Carmichael,
and I strongly recommend this book.
- So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself, and whatever,
your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- If I didn't make it as
an actor, writer, painter,
I would have gone into
something in the physical vein,
something where, I would have
liked to have been a coach
of some sort, because I enjoy
motivating a great deal,
I really do.
I like to motivate.
- Everybody around you.
- Yes, I do.
I've been discovered, I've
been around for a while,
all I want to do is get a
certain kind of momentum going
and do films that I'm not
ashamed of or really disappoint
my audience, you know,
I'm not the new young kid
on the block by any means,
I've been around quite a while,
that's all, I just want to pick up,
I feel like George
Foreman, he kind of left
on a kind of dubious
note, I want to come back
and do the things that I
do best and really push it
as far as humanly possible that I can do,
I like the challenge, that's all.
If people were to say that
the money at a certain point
is not important, I think they would be,
I think they would be reveling
in a serious case of mendacity,
(laughs) I believe that
when you get to a
certain level and you see
one performer is getting
a number right away,
you feel as though, okay, to be respected,
it becomes a numbers game.
I think more importantly
it is to the agent,
than quite often it is to
the actor, for example,
in the film I just completed
I was paid nothing, zero.
- That's Cop Land.
- Absolutely nothing, I mean...
- You'll get some back in profit if it--
- If it does, you gamble.
- If it does well.
- But you see, that to
me is, I've never been,
quote, a mercenary,
at one time I thought I was,
but it's not about money,
otherwise I wouldn't waive this,
and I would take the safe route--
- And it's not about buying
more art or buying more cars
or buying more homes,
- No, no no,
no, no, no.
- Or any of that stuff,
You're way beyond that.
- No, really, I have all the
material comforts one needs,
now it's all about the, (sigh)
the library of memories you leave behind.
- The body of work.
- Exactly right.